[موسيقى]
لأنني كنت أساعد الناس ، ولهذا
السبب فعلت ذلك
وأعتقد أنك ستكون سعيدًا في المستقبل
أيضًا لأن هذا سيكون سؤالك التالي
ولكنك ستكون سعيدًا في
المستقبل ، إنها وظيفة مهمة جدًا
لأننا  سيكون لدينا عدد كبير وأعتقد أنه
سيكون لدينا 22 فريقًا كبيرًا جدًا وأعتقد
أنه سيكون لدينا 24 أكبر.
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، لقد كانوا مخطئين فيما
فعلوه ونحن نتعامل مع  رئيس الولايات المتحدة
الذي من الواضح أنه
رئيس يتمتع بشعبية استنادًا إلى كل ما
تراه وكذلك هم وفيسبوك وأعتقد أنهم ارتكبوا
خطأً فادحًا
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنها في أدنى نقطة وصلت إليها على
الإطلاق ،
لا أعتقد ذلك  لقد كانت في
وضع مثل هذا لم نعد نحترمها
بعد الآن إذا نظرت إلى ما يحدث في
أه أفغانستان مع الانسحاب الذي
كان أعتقد أنه أكثر اللحظات إحراجًا
في تاريخ بلدنا وأنت
تنظر إلى حدودنا ما يحدث.
حدودنا تنظر إلى تكلفة
الطاقة التي كنا مستقلين عن الطاقة
لم نعد ننظر إلى العديد من
الأشياء المختلفة التي يمكنني التحدث عنها
طوال اليوم ، نعم ومن المؤسف أن ما
حدث للولايات المتحدة
[موسيقى]
جيدًا يستخدمون الطمع أو فيروس الصين
كما أسميه
بالسرقة والتلاعب  وسرقوا
انتخابات وأرسلوا الملايين والملايين
من بطاقات الاقتراع لا أحد يعرف إلى أين ذهبوا
في كثير من الحالات وكان ذلك وصمة
عار والجميع يعرف ذلك
[موسيقى]
كان هناك تجمع حاشد وإذا
نظرتم كان تجمعًا ضخمًا  مع
مئات ومئات الآلاف من
الأشخاص ، أعتقد أنه كان أكبر حشد
تحدثت عنه من قبل ، إذا نظرت إلى
ما حدث وعدت
ودرسته حقًا ،
فقد شعروا
بالغضب الشديد والانزعاج الشديد ، ولذا فإنهم أعني أن الناس
يبكون  غاضب جدًا الآن
إذا خسرت الانتخابات ، لا يتصرف الأشخاص
بهذه الطريقة
ولكنهم كانوا يعلمون أننا فزنا في
الانتخابات وذهبوا إلى هناك
[موسيقى]